(piano music)
- [Phillip] My name is
Phillip William Mick,
and I'm from Auburn, Indiana.
(bicycle bell rings)
I was getting bullied
ever since second grade,
third grade, fourth
grade, and fifth grade.
They were teasing on me,
picking on me, and all that.
It was getting really bad and
I thought this might need to be fixed.
(motorcycle engine noise)
(piano music)
I was getting bullied for many years.
People started cursing at me ‘cause,
they're wearing all rich stuff and
I'm just wearing cheap stuff ‘cause,
my parents can't afford the rich stuff.
They were calling me
fatso cause of my weight.
My mom had had enough of it.
She stepped in, talked with Brett, and
he helps me by getting
all these bikers together
to help me stop the bullying.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Brett Warfield director of
United Motorcycle Enthusiasts.
We ride together and help support
our local communities do charity work.
We ride to do good.
It's a brotherhood.
- That's what it's about.
- Get along instead of being hateful.
Get along with people.
- You gotta love everybody.
- Exactly.
- It started on the first day of school.
We met at a restaurant.
50 Bikers were there.
The bikers took me to
school to support, and
tell all those people
that bullying isn't cool
and you should stop it.
And instead of saying it, they showed it.
- Good for you, man.
Now you want to know something,
we all love you.
We want you to know that.
- They only thought that a
few people would understand,
but actually there's tons of people.
Now, there's a lot of kids
who wants to be my friends.
It just relieves all of my
feelings and all of that.
It was my first time on a motorcycle.
It felt like I was flying.
(music gets louder)
Me and Brett are trying
to stop bullying because
many kids think that
the bully's the big guy,
but really the big guy is actually you.
- Pay attention to your children.
Teach your kids empathy.
Open you're heart up.
See how you would feel.
Love is the answer.
(gentle music)